d'
accord d'accord où est
oh il ne bouge pas
alors alors alors allez-y d'
accord
autour de l'île ici
oui
ralentissez un peu pour que vous puissiez tourner à gauche
possible
une fois que je vais au travail d'accord
merci
maintenant
très lumineux
devant
comment ça se sent
j'ai un moment
oh  merde désolé
du direct ouais
bonjour d'accord il y a
trois petites maisons des
maisons oranges en bas
étranger
ouais d'accord
viens sous cette ombre
hein oh
c'est que
notre exposition est devenue sombre
peut-être pas je ne sais pas d'accord arrête un
instant d'accord
bien sûr
d'accord
je suis désolé
je suppose que le tir est vraiment là dans un
peu d'inclinaison vers
le bas d'accord en bas
c'est
bon ouais c'est bien
combien de gars ici d'accord d'accord ouais
reviens dans l'autre sens
euh
n'importe quoi ouais
ouais
d'accord ressemble à
un cheval
ressemble à la mi-temps
étranger
alors
bonjour
un peu brumeux ici
un peu un peu de lueur nuage ouais ouais
étranger
pouvons-nous faire demi-tour pour que je puisse voir le euh
ouais super
donc d'accord
glacier
étranger
non
hmm
salut
étranger
parce que oh la lumière n'est pas c'est
probablement vraiment génial ce soir puisque
c'est juste
ici
alors sachez juste voler quand nous avons de
très très bonnes lumières
puisque nous restons à l'hôtel pendant
environ deux ou trois jours d'accord nous pouvons nous
installer
ici
d'accord il y a
oh ouais c'est un dur labeur je ne travaille pas c'est de
la marche en hélicoptère
je bouge juste quelques pogs
viens un peu
la caméra
ok c'est bien c'est
bien ouais tu peux voler normalement maintenant
voler droit
avec tes pieds normaux
ça va  pour être assez soigné quand est-ce que nous
arrivons à ce qu'il y ait un
passage bas un de ces gros rochers
ici quelques-uns de ces rochers
oh ouais
je suis euh plus de deux mille ici pas de
problème
il y a vraiment de gros rochers ici
d'accord
allez là où le le  l'eau claire est pour que
vous puissiez voir un reflet ouais ça
va être vraiment cool
est une
autre très grosse boule de glace n'est-ce pas mais il
y a un reflet ouais le reflet
arrive
hong kong
drôle parce qu'avec l'œil vous pouvez
vraiment voir le reflet mais sur  la
caméra tu sais ouais eh bien on la verra
dans une minute quand on arrivera à l'endroit dégagé
ouais d'accord désolé sceau au revoir bonjour au
revoir la
dernière fois que j'ai vu un coup comme ça c'était en
nouvelle zélande
droit étranger d'accord
arrêter l'enregistrement s'il vous plait
2000 s'il vous plait